[Applause]
Thank You Hannah and thank you very much
everybody for coming tonight
it is going to be a really important
event because the possibility
probability perhaps that Jeremy Corbyn
will become the 55th prime minister of
this country the Prime Minister who'll
be in power on the 300th anniversary of
that first prime minister Robert Walpole
this is a very serious and real
possibility and that's what we're
debating tonight it is the motion is
about that he's unfit to be Prime
Minister it's not about easy a good or a
bad leader it is specifically can you
see him walking into number 10 and does
he have the qualities that Prime
Minister's require although frankly
looking at the qualities of some of the
54 who have pretty deceived it would
have been his predecessors you worry
whether they had many of the qualities
themselves so we are going to be
debating this Jeremy Corbyn is unfit to
be Prime Minister and the first speaker
for this motion is on my immediate right
hi Jacobson novelist journalist best
known perhaps perhaps for the finger
question which won him the 2010 Man
Booker Prize a prominent critic of
Jeremy Corbyn and in particular his
handling of anti-semitism in the labour
party Howard would you like to be
walking up
as you go
[Applause]
every speaker has a maximum of ten
minutes
Howard that is now 959 mr. chairman
ladies and gentlemen something tells me
you're expecting to hear me call Jeremy
Corbyn an anti-semite there's been a bit
about this in the press and I well you
know but I'm not going to call him
anything he says he isn't an anti-semite
Hamas says he isn't an anti-semite the
white supremacist David Duke says he
isn't an anti-semite and that's good
enough for me
you might think I'm being ironical
ladies and gentlemen I am incapable of
irony we all know what an anti-semite
looks like he wears Jack boots a
swastika armband and he shouts
Juden raus Jeremy Corbyn wears a British
home stores vest under his shirt and his
softly spoken anti-semites accused Jews
of killing Jesus Corbin is an atheist
and seems not to mind whether we did all
we didn't whether that's because Jesus
was Jewish and killing him meant one
less Jew in the world is not for me to
say and he doesn't deny the Holocaust
mind you he knows a man who does in fact
he knows a surprising number of men who
do that he denies ever having been in
their company until photographs turn up
of him rubbing noses with them at the
grave sides of mass murderers offering
to show them his belief systems if
they'll show him theirs
gosh they're almost the same size should
come as no surprise you can't spend your
whole life in the company of blood libel
errs and Holocaust deniers and expect to
remember them all by name if I may quote
from Oscar Wilde missing play the self
importance of being Jeremy to associate
with one anti-semite you don't know to
be anti-semitic mr. Corbyn may be
regarded as a misfortune to associate
with anti-semites on a regular basis
looks like a predilection but look when
I think of the scoundrels I've hung
around with I know how easy it is to get
people wrong even when they turn up to
meet you wearing hoods and holding
burning crosses and Jeremy is it ok if I
call him
me has never actually been what you
could call observant take that mural he
championed showing bankers playing
monopoly on the naked backs of the
world's oppressed you and I ladies and
gentlemen would look at those greedy
grasping hooked nose syphilitic
Zionistic finances and recognize them at
once a straight out of the Julius
Streicher I spy book of Jews but so
innocent of anti-semitic character is
caricature sorry but so innocent of
anti-semitic caricature is Jeremy that
he didn't see anything remotely
offensive I didn't look closely he
explained later how many times does he
have to say that for God's sake I might
have been there but I don't think I was
involved I don't remember I didn't look
at closely
if this reminds you of those who live
downwind of the chimneys of
bergen-belsen claiming never to have
smelt anything out of the ordinary I say
you have suspicious nature's Corbin is a
busy man busy men must take emotional
shortcuts there's an image of a blood
sucking June it's identical to the image
of the blood sucking Jew I already carry
in my head snap good there I wonder be
such a thing as an in advertent
anti-semite Jeremy claims to be a peace
a peace maker a peace maker brings
warring parties together why then do we
only ever see him taking Palestinians to
tea could it be that he just can't
remember to ask the Israelis tugger have
forgotten to invite the Jews again
unless perish the thought
it isn't peace he wants after all but
the destruction but the triumph of those
he calls comrades and the destruction of
those he doesn't according to his
supporters Jeremy Corbyn doesn't have a
racist bone in his body just a question
but what is a racist phone and how do
you know whether another person has one
there are 64 bones in the human arm
alone can one be absolutely certain that
Jeremy doesn't
feel even the tiniest twinge of bone
ache somewhere between the scapula and
the humerus
when he sees an alien figure such as I
coming towards him on his Lincoln green
carrying the collected speeches of
Benjamin Disraeli and humming my
addition mama and what are we to make
speaking of Corbin's unconscious of his
inability ever to disavow anti-semitism
without reminding us of his lifelong
opposition to all forms of racism which
is like answering the question are you a
wife beater with the assurance that you
always buy the big issue because an anti
suppose anti-semitism
ladies and gentlemen isn't quite a
racism it's closer to a superstition
embedded in theology shrouded in
medieval irrationality updated to suit
leftist economics and exhumed whenever a
single explanation for all the evils of
the world is sought to talk of
anti-semitism as a racism is a
contradiction in terms
for Jeremy Corbyn since in his eyes Jews
are neither downtrodden nor exploited
but are as usurers colonialists and
conspirators the very source and fount
of racism themselves once whole Jews to
be racist and Zionism a racist endeavor
then no anti-semite can ever be a racist
himself and any definition that says
otherwise must be amended that's the
psychology now the science
Corbin's political life has been
determined by Newton's first law of
inertia which states that an object will
stay at rest forever as long as nothing
pushes or pulls on it in physics that's
something that might push or pull it is
another object in motion in socialist
politics it is a view contradictory to
your own Corbyn averts his face whenever
he hears the word Jew and rolls his eyes
whenever he is asked the question
because he fears the chaos
otherwise known as a change of mind that
might ensue from accepting there's
another way of looking at the world I
will spend my remaining seconds I don't
mean in life I mean of this speech
telling you why it matters to everyone
not just choose that a man so spiteful
sanctimonious and obdurate should never
be allowed to do to the country what
he's doing to the party those who revere
Corbyn see it as a virtue that he has
never changed his views mr. chairman it
is only a virtue to be faithful to one's
views if those views are worth staying
faithful to to persist in a small
erroneous MMus is the mark of a fool to
persist in a great erroneous nassif the
mark of a dangerous fool the ideology in
which corbin has been pickled for half a
century without warn before it even
reached him it oversaw the death of
millions that the ideologies he opposes
have scarcely done any better is not an
argument for his you don't have to love
the west to refuse the embraces of those
whose sole ambition is to blow the West
apart especially if you wish to call
yourself a pacifist this should have
been a golden summer for labor the
nightmare that is brexit the hell that
is jacob riis MOG the out of season
pantomime that is Boris Johnson from all
these labor ought to have delivered us
but Corbin did as much as anyone to make
bricks it happen with his feeble or non
support for remaining do you remember
that question how much do you favor and
staying seven seven and a half per
cylinder
that was one to get us to the barricades
was it not ladies and gentlemen the
wrong man ladies and gentlemen the wrong
man in the wrong time espousing the
wrong causes I am nothing if not fair
people who were limited in everything
but the pleasure they take in themselves
are ten a penny in all political parties
they halt the peripheries like ghosts of
the Christmases they don't believe in
past backing losing causes throwing tea
parties for murderers and looking
saintly mr corbyn's miss fort
June was to be lifted from those
peripheries and dumped haplessly in the
centre ladies and gentlemen not just for
our sake but for his for theirs well
someone please have pity and dump him
back
[Applause]
Thank You Howard for that measured and
calm introductory speech our first
speaker against the motion is Chris
Williamson Labour MP for Derby North a
key ally of Jeremy Corbyn on the back
benches described by the New Statesman
no less during the 2017 general election
as the most Pro Jeremy Corbyn candidate
in England's most marginal constituency
this is Chris Williamson thank you very
much indeed chair and um hi yeah unlike
the previous speak I'm going to try and
stick to the motion and I aim to
demonstrate that Jeremy Corbyn is indeed
fit to be Prime Minister but let me
start by thanking it sergeant squared
for arranging this event and I must say
that when I joined the Labour Party as a
19 year old apprentice bricklayer back
in 1976 I never imagined speaking at
such a highbrow event anyway I'm sorry
to say that I think Howard's indulging
in a complete miss characterization of
Jeremy in my opinion Jeremy Corbyn will
prove to be the best Prime Minister this
country has ever had just look what he's
achieved just look what he's achieved
already the Labour Party's membership
has more than tripled since he was
elected leader in fact Labour's
memberships considerably higher than
every other political party put together
but it's not just labour soaring
membership that's impressive he's
restored hope to millions of people
who'd given up on politics and he's
inspired young people in a way that
we've never seen before so what's his
secret well the truth is it's pretty
straightforward
labour is now offering a real choice
free-market economics has failed
millions of British people and
working-class communities have been
hardest hit fractures promise of a
shareholding property-owning democracy
was a fantasy but the confidence tricks
worked and delivered substantial
electoral success in fact that
was so successful that he gave birth to
Tony Blair and New Labour Margaret
Thatcher even said that Tony Blair and
New Labour were her greatest
achievements because she said we forced
our opponents to change their minds but
that left millions of Britons
politically homeless turn out selections
fell while public cynicism about
politics grew despite the financial
crash ten years ago much of the
political class and the mainstream media
are still enthralled to neoliberalism
neither are speaking to the needs of the
country for the last four decades we've
seen rising inequality but the preceding
thirty four years when inequality
narrowed to such an extent that is a 19
year old apprentice bricklayer in 1976 I
was able to buy my own house it was a
brand-new 3-bedroom semi-detached house
backing onto a nice waterfront in a
desirable village 8 miles south of Derby
and it was only three times my annual
wage so another world is possible
but it requires political will that's
why Corbin's message that he'll make a
future Labour government work for the
many not the few is resonating just look
at the polls there's never been an
easier time to campaign for the Labour
Party most people support the individual
policies that Jeremy is promoting and by
way of evidence jars brand Ruth went to
Guildford the capital of the Home
Counties looking for secret socialists
and he found plenty
he stopped people on the street and
asked them if they supported things like
higher taxes or peeping people earning
over a hundred and fifty thousand pounds
at all yes yes just to support that
regulating the private rented sector yes
that's a very good idea oh I totally
support that
ending privatisation in the National
Health Service well I'm totally with you
on that they said scrapping tuition fees
absolutely about time and clamping down
on tax avoidance yes we must definitely
do that there was almost universal
support for those policies and then jars
brandriss
turned his clipboard around and said the
these are the policies of Jeremy Corbyn
there is mainstream popular support
therefore for Jeremy's policy the truth
is that deregulation privatization and
the commodification of public services
was disastrous the one-dimensional
obsession with financial services was
wrongheaded - and the absence of an
industrial strategy has driven millions
into low-paid precarious employment
working-class kids can't hope to
replicate what I did as a 19 year old
apprentice our industrial heartlands
have been abandoned and people are
searching for answers the post-crash
response has been hopeless and dangerous
QE for example actually exacerbated
inequality even the right-wing Spectator
magazine described it as the biggest
transfer of wealth to the rich of any
government policy in recent documented
history but the last 8 years of
austerity has generated real resentment
far-right populism is on the rise
fuelled by poverty and insecurity
meanwhile the mainstream media
perpetuate the politics of fear by
scapegoating migrants and that's then
used to whip up racism political
centrism offers nothing in these
circumstances it's just another name the
free market status quo and that ship has
sailed
just look at Italy Greece and even
France where macarons poll ratings have
plummeted and this is a guy who models
himself on Tony Blair so there's no
political science salvation in that
direction but Corbin's program for
common sense socialism offers a populist
antidote to the politics of fear in fact
jeremy corbyn's Labour Party is the only
traditional left-of-centre Party in
Europe that's prevented the drift of its
core vote thanks to Jeremy Corbyn
Labour's answer the demands of those
left behind voters not by scapegoating
migrants not by whipping up racism and
not by moral panics over crime or
foreign enemies Corbin's labour office
something better class politics is back
on the agenda but let there be no doubt
who we're talking about when we say for
the many not the few because that may be
where
some of Howard's anxieties lie Labour's
taking aim at an elite defined by their
class perspective and nothing else those
who speculate on our economy who avoid
paying tax who profit from privatized
utilities like gas water electricity and
the trains and as for the debate about
the IHRA
examples of anti-semitism let me be
clear one of the reasons this has been a
sticking point for labour is because we
genuinely care about the politics of
anti racism and Jeremy Corbyn yes has
been fighting racism all his life the
debate in labor has been exclusively
about preserving the right to speak up
for Palestinians and to legitimately
criticize the Israeli government I want
to say this there are three voices in
this debate but we rarely hear from all
three first there are the diverse voices
in the Jewish community many of whom of
a strong and very understandable deep
connection to Israel second there's the
labor party which must write policy in
the interests of the nation and
according to the party's values and
third there are the Palestinian people
who let's be clear were violently
displaced when Israel was established we
cannot and we must not try to hide this
fact just because we find it distasteful
or uncomfortable but Labour's policy
towards Israel Palestine conflict is for
a two-state solution it's not an attempt
to reverse history just like peace in
Northern Ireland in fact peace we're in
whatever form can only be achieved by
dialogue so let me return to the motion
at hand it might seem odd but the 68
year old Jeremy Corbyn has modernized
labour making it fit to overcome the
challenges facing the country a
manifesto last year saw Labor's biggest
teasing increase in vote share since
1945 over 80% of the British public
support regulation of tax avoiding
digital digital text giants like Amazon
Google and Facebook 80% of the British
public support raising the minimum wage
establishing a publicly owned national
investment bank and borrowing to invest
polls are over 55 percent these policies
represent the new center ground of
British politics they represent a
direction
that no other labor leader was prepared
to go before Corbin never mind another
political party we live in a country
where the wealthiest 10% whole nine
hundred times more than the poorest 10%
and yet we're the six richest country on
the planet how can we let this go on but
let's talk about the man himself there's
so much said about him it's hard to keep
up apparently he's a terrorist
sympathizer but he's also a pacifist
he's a weak leader but he's also
overbearing he's the leader of a cult
but he's not charismatic what I see in
Jeremy every time he stands at that
despatch box even under the glare from
both sides of the chamber is a man with
a strength of moral convictions and yet
these convictions are far from dogmatic
the special thing about Jeremy is that
he's a politician that listens
everywhere you go with him is a complete
nightmare he speaks to everyone and I
mean he really speaks and he really
listens is that not the character of a
man who's fits a government fit to
govern because what do we mean by
governing John MacDonald's fond of
saying when Labour goes into government
we all go into government and Jeremy is
above all a Democrat he wants ordinary
people to have a say in how their world
is shaped isn't that refreshing is this
not the attitude we need to heal a
nation divided by four decades of
neoliberalism and made worse by a
government that's inflicted eight years
of counterproductive austerity people on
the Left
often say that's at times of crisis we
must choose socialism or barbarism well
today we have a similar choice
investments or austerity dialogue or
conflicts democracy or dogma the choice
today is between Corbin's labor or a
Tory Twilight Zone
[Music]
powerful and passionate from Chris and
brilliantly on time you came in just as
that clock said ten minutes precisely
Anna Sabri is going to speak next for
the notion coming up now to the podium
Conservative MP for Brock Stowe in
Nottingham sure and former business
minister until 2016
a prominent critic of Jeremy Corbyn Anna
thinks that Jeremy is a hard left
Marxist she's a key member of the
people's vote campaign for a referendum
on the brexit deal Anna you have your 10
minutes beginning now well thank you
very much and thank you everybody for
coming along what I'd like you first of
all to do is to remember when you were
back at school whichever school you may
have gone to there's I think it's almost
impossible to imagine that you didn't
have a head teacher and throughout your
life you will have had in your
experiences times when you will have
encountered or it may have been you
yourself who has been a leader so we
have all had experiences of what we
would expect to see in a leader a good
leader or a bad leader and perhaps not
so great leader so what are the
qualities that make a great leader
because of course you need to have those
qualities to be the most important
important leader in our country which is
to be our prime minister I suggest as
you consider that some of the following
qualities the integrity competence an
ability to inspire an ability to be able
to take decisions an ability to have
accountability in your leadership to
have courage and most of all perhaps in
the political field as a Prime Minister
to be successful I listened with care to
Chris's speech when he spoke in such
glowing terms
about Jeremy Corbyn spectacularly
forgetting of course that last year we
had a general election and whilst it's
right that he won a few more seats he
spectacularly failed because he lost as
leader of the Labour Party at a time
when arguably it would have been the
most easiest win of any general election
because of the profound failings of my
party when it went into that campaign
which as you might imagine I don't
intend to dwell upon but and I really
wish you hadn't applauded now if you
haven't been convinced by the
magnificent speech of Howard over there
may I give you some other suggestions
and ideas as to why Jeremy Corbyn is
profoundly unfit to not only be our
prime minister but to be the leader of
one of the most important political
parties in the world even though it's a
party I obviously never been a member of
I don't subscribe to in seek to fight I
never less recognized what an important
political party it is and I know what it
has meant for so many people in our
history and in our country one of the
most peculiarly awful moments in the
time that I've been in Parliament I was
elected in 2010 I'm no criminal
barrister and I came into politics will
return quite later on in my life
we're standing in Parliament Square just
down the road there surrounded by
members of the Jewish community who was
staging a protest against anti-semitism
in their own party the Labour Party and
I sat in Parliament listening to
speeches from members of parliament who
were Jewish he talked about
anti-semitism in their lives on a scale
that they had never experienced before
but the most remarkable and most
disturbing and distressing speeches with
those from labour Jewish MP
who talked about this rise in
anti-semitism from within their own
party and that is a party that Jeremy
Corbyn has now led for what is it almost
three it is three years almost he should
be ashamed of what state he has taken
that great political party into and it's
it's not just the Jewish MPs in the
Labor Party who make complaint it's the
women to speak to women Labour MPs about
the abuse that they have received during
his tenure by members of their party and
in particular the abuse they have
suffered by supporters and from
supporters of Jeremy Corbyn and Howard
rightly mentioned brexit that I think
Chris mentioned it at all astonishing
isn't it the most important matter issue
decision that our country has taken
since the Second World War and as Howard
rightly identified again Corbin
spectacularly failed to lead his party
his people his voters into making the
right decision for our country by his
not just his lackluster performance but
backed by that 7.5 that he gave and of
course he said that because he doesn't
believe that we should have stayed it
should remain that in the European Union
we've heard from Chris about the return
of the class struggle he is the perfect
embodiment of what has happened to the
Labor Party the return of the old hard
left it's nothing new I remember it from
my days as a student these are the
people who are now back in charge these
are the people who are running the
Labour Party and on brexit this issue
that dominates our politics what do we
see from the Labour Party where is the
leadership where is the policies
none of these things exist dragging and
screaming they were to accept a customs
union
they still haven't embraced the merits
of the single market because perversely
and bizarrely from this great party all
this is a great leader that Chris
eulogizes who apparently believes in
immigration they still won't come out
and make the positive case for
immigration that must and should be made
I say to their eternal shame they have
shown no leadership and what does that
mean what has that resulted in this is
how I see it well you could say the
official or position is a bunch of Tory
backbenchers like me and some very brave
moderates on the Labor Party side as
well who do our best to put some sanity
and reason into this terrible crisis
that our country will face if we don't
get a good deal or even better if we
were to remain within the European Union
god help us if we have that hard brexit
what it means in my opinion is there are
millions and millions of people in our
country who believe that nobody speaks
for them they are good sensible moderate
tolerant people who have long occupied
the center ground of British political
life they have seen the Labour Party
being taken over by the Marxist the
Trotskyists the rabble that have existed
only extremes of politics for a long
time
and chris says these are the people
these hundreds of thousands that
apparently jeremy has brought back to
the Labour Party when I think Ed
Miliband would say it was his
three-pound membership and had a bit to
do with it that's what Jeremy did he
took advantage of that now I would agree
only in this way i think that corbin has
inspired a section of our young people
who understandably in my view were
disenchanted who are ideologically sztyc
who wanted to hear stuff perhaps they
hadn't heard from main political classes
for far too long and I think he caught
that mood I think he wrote that wave and
he did it very well
but of course as they now see what it
really means
Corbin's Corbin's politics as they now
see and understand the anti-semitism
that has always run through the extreme
left I believe they are quite rightly
turning away so he's apparently got even
more members into the labour party this
is his it seems only victory and success
cause Chris forgets and doesn't tell you
about the 103 resignations from the
Labour front bench during jeremy
corbyn's tenure and you know that within
the Labour Party as it exists in
Parliament he has very little support
amongst members of his own party who sit
in parliament and I would uh I would
argue that speaks volumes because I
don't want to play the man I do want to
talk about his policies but I think the
clocks against me though what I would
say is this on all the big occasions
like yesterday when the Prime Minister
stood up and talked about what had
happened in Salisbury
on all the great occasions korban just
can't do it
he just hasn't got the ability to say
the sort of thing that you would expect
from a credible leader of a major
political party especially the leader of
the Opposition Ian Blackford Vince Cable
spoke better than he did yesterday and
even when he has a superb open goal and
some would say that my Prime Minister
often stands in Parliament in front of
that very wide open goal spectacularly
on every occasion he misses it and why
is that because he is somebody who has
always been on the absolute fringes
carping from the sidelines somebody who
probably the biggest decision of his
life was what was going to be the
vegetarian option at the Palestinian
solidarity meeting
but I make I make light of it but ladies
and gentlemen in my respectful
submission to you there really is no
debate whichever way you cut it this man
is not fit to be our prime minister
nevermind the leader the Labour Party
so thank you very much indeed
Anna for that I think we we got the
general drift there of what you thought
about Jeremy Corbyn which after all is
the point of the debate now we're going
to have against the motion and for
Jeremy Corbyn ash Sokka ash is senior
editor at Navarra media which as I'm
sure you know is a left-leaning online
news outlet where her work focuses on
race gender class and power ash as you
will shortly discover is a prominent
supporter of Jeremy Corbyn ash
I'll uh keep it brief what the are
we all doing here I don't mean this in
any philosophical sense real talk
what the hell are we all doing here love
island has finished but that's still no
excuse really to spend your evening in
this way I mean it's my job to chat crap
for a living but if I'm being honest
with you I really hate these things
a slot up on the stage come here we
prowl around for our allotted 10 minutes
given it the full Gordon Brown if we are
able telling you that Jeremy Corbyn is
either the cause of all the solution to
all your life's problems and we nor over
the greatest hits' brexit populism
foreign policy anti-semitism civility
and then we put it in your hands the
audience the demos who paid between 15
and 30 quid for the privilege of voting
and we practice our faces for losing
gracefully we hoped that we would be
magnanimous in the event of victory and
then every single person in this room
every one of us goes home with a
comforting hum of self-satisfaction for
what we have done in this room is none
other than the lofty business of
politics itself which is utter breath
right all we're doing in here or even
just around the corner in the Palace of
Westminster your place of work mate or
in Broadcasting House is trying to keep
alive a collective delusion that
politics resides in these approximations
of the Oxford Union debating society and
that's why Jeremy Corbyn scares the
bejesus out of so many people not
because here's a cheque spy who
moonlights as a member of Hezbollah all
while working undercover for the
Provisional IRA of course while at the
same time similar
taneous Lee trying to do a hard brexit
and subvert the referendum outcome it's
because Corbin as leader of the Labour
Party is an expression of the social
forces poised to change Britain on a
scale which it hasn't seen since 1945
because at its heart the project of
Corbin ISM is the building of power
outside the hallowed halls of
Westminster it's about power in our
neighborhoods in our unions and our
workplaces our schools and our community
centres our social networks both on and
offline I want to speak in this register
the register of movements I want to
speak in naive Anne's words the language
of priorities so hands up full
disclosure I am NOT a Labour Party
member like you know what's that saying
about not wanting to be a member of any
club that would have you in it I go with
that my heart is with movement politics
they always have been it's been that way
in my family for generations so my
grandmother came here at the age of 17
she was greeted by Teddy boys spitting
bile at her my mother similarly would
often put her own five-foot-one body in
between London's black and brown youth
and the racist police officers and/or
National Front members sometimes it was
hard to tell the difference between them
and neither of them had very much
positive to say about the Labour Party
and this was in the age of war Anna
calls the older left back in the 70s
which is apparently there's the same one
that we've got now they weren't any big
fan of this old left many of the unions
were hostile to black in Asians
participating in organizing with them
often the same Labour councillors who
are trying to organize events against
the nf would be letting out their
council properties for the NFT use at
the same time a gross act of hypocrisy
and my mum and my grandmother's eyes so
they committed themselves wholesale to
movement politics outside of the Labour
Party
though funnily enough both my mom and my
grandmother have fond memories of a
certain scruffy Haringey Council er
later MP for Islington North joining
them on the anti apartheid picket line
and in my mom's case supporting her
campaign for specialist domestic
violence services for women of color and
is in fair tradition the tradition of my
mom and my grandma that I am first and
foremost an anti-racist activists and it
is for this reason that I say
unequivocally that we must fight
anti-semitism Islamophobia anti black
racism xenophobia in the Labour Party
and the left at large tooth and nail and
we cannot in any way deny the fact that
these issues exist on the left and they
exist on the left because the left
exists in society takes some specific
forms on the left but it's essentially
the same things that we see elsewhere
and any call by loyalist who's telling
you that we don't have to do race do
anti racism and the Labour Party is
missing the whole point of Corbin's
politics in their entirety
he has always it's been a dedicated
anti-racist activists and the women of
my family knew something and I think or
been in his days as an activist knew
something to that electoral politics
alone cannot deliver substantial social
change like that anti-racist change
which is so needed in our society indeed
as the slogan goes there is no justice
there is just us skipping forward a few
decades we knew this in 2010 I was a
student activist who along with
thousands of others up and down the
country responded to the betrayal of the
Liberal Democrats and even woke Tories
like Anna Sabri who troubled the tuition
fees by occupying our universities just
down the road on Westminster Bridge we
were kettled we were charged out with
horses in the freezing cold and there
are only two MPs who came to see us
during this time when we were sleeping
on a cold university floor because the
university administration had cut off
the heating
cold Hermus which is quite crap Jeremy
Corbyn and John McDonald and they've
never forgotten the debt that they owe
to these social movements they know that
when they enter number 10 they're not
going to be all that interested in
parliamentary horse trading meeting up
with their opposite numbers maybe trying
to engineer some kind of parliamentary
split - I don't know
scrap over six percent of the votes like
many centrist MPs instead they will be
meeting with people like disabled people
against the cuts they'll be meeting with
the families of people who've lost loved
ones to police violence they will be
meeting with people directly affected by
austerity and using their voices to
guide the direction of policy in this
country that's social movement politics
the funny thing about both Howard and
Anna's speeches is that they
acknowledged that the summer should have
really been an open goal for labour
polls haven't shifted very much
the awful depressing thing about this
anti-semitism crisis is that there's not
much cut through to the rest of the
British public everyone is deeply
alienated and turned off from seeing the
serious business of racism reduced to a
cheap opportunity for political
point-scoring
I'm deeply depressed buyer
I'm deeply depressed that for your
powerful words against anti-semitism
they were powerful Anna that you've had
nothing to say about the crisis of
Islamophobia within your own party from
triggers such as very nasty birth
corchran enquiry and has been
stonewalled at every turn I also don't
remember a great deal of criticism of
your colleagues like Michael fabricant
sharing Islamophobic memes and these
memes are very similar to the form in
which anti-semitism takes I don't agree
with Howard that anti-semitism is
divorced from all other kinds of racism
I agree with Edward Saeed who says that
anti-semitism and Islamophobia are both
nourished at the same source nurtured by
the same stream I as a Muslim cannot be
safe for my Jewish brothers and sisters
are unsafe and vice versa so I've got
about a minute left I'll probably and a
bit sooner than that cuz I think the
natives are getting a bit Restless I
don't actually care about jeremy
corbyn's personality I mean I think he's
a nice enough guy reminds me of the
Werther's original grandad I care about
us I care about if we are ready for
government because the Tories they'd
rather talk about personality than
policy because that's the terrain on
which they lose and it's up to us to
keep the conversation on the issues that
really affect us every day it's not
question of whether we trust Jeremy
Corbyn to be a fit Prime Minister when
he walks into number 10 it's about
whether we trust ourselves to walk in
behind him so to paraphrase someone
whose name I've forgotten after tonight
catch up on the kroger at programs that
you missed and then go back into your
neighborhoods and prepare for government
[Applause]
so ash passionate also unconventional
quiet
I thought understated beginning I mean
why the are we here after all
great let's begin with just getting some
movement amongst the panel but before
then I do have the results very hot off
the press from people's democracy and it
is on the motion is in fact in truth
Jeremy Corbyn unfit to be Prime Minister
well apparently 66% of you think he is
unfit 13 I think he's just fine and 21%
of you undecided so we can take that
vote again I didn't go for the long
rigmarole of reminds you of procedure
because most of you have been here
before but we're going to have another
vote and I'm going to read out that to
see how people have shifted the 21% I'm
gonna say we're gonna be Australian here
and say that you can't be undecided you
simply have to have a few I mean come on
why have you come out here if you can't
pick up in mind whether he's fit or
unfit what are you doing here why didn't
you watch what watch love Ireland
because there's no law but you could see
it on on iPlayer or something so you
have to vote and I'm gonna want to see
real movement there and okay so let's
just get Howard I got the point
Howard that you think Jeremy is a bit of
an anti-semite but why does that make
him unfit to be Prime Minister given
that most of the 54 ancestry Mike you
know to be honest it in most of the
previous Prime Minister you only watch
them contrast beans have been racists
many many previous prime ministers have
been racist well I'll tell you something
back between ourselves since no one is
listening I don't care that much either
I don't care that much what I care
is the lies that he spins to protect his
anti-semitism what I what I cannot bear
is this is a man pickled in sanctimony
pickled by his supporters in even
further sanctimony but this account of
I've fought racism all my life
what is that worth if the first time
he's brought to brought to a test here
is a problem of racism
how does he cope he bottles it he looks
the other way the whole description that
we've had of Corbin tonight
is a bit of a person we've never seen
yesterday upon the stair I met a man who
wasn't there he's a man who isn't there
easy there actress is either and is he a
liar you see the thing is when you say
is he there it's like you're asking me
is he there is some kind of proto father
figure I mean I think that this idea of
Jeremy Corbyn as a totem onto which you
project all your hopes are indeed all
your fears or your anxieties or your
kind of bogeyman is ridiculous you see
there is a principled anti-racist who
has voted in favor of anti-racist policy
when people on this panel have not
who've stood by migrants who've stood by
people who've been victims of police
once he's done all those things that is
a matter of fact and record do I think
the Labour Party's been quick enough to
respond to the anti-semitism crisis I
think there's been a great deal of
bureaucratic inertia but I don't think
that any other parties have done much
better when tackling the worst problems
in their own circles okay Chris is he a
liar because I would note the not
telling lies is an absolutely necessary
requirement for not being Prime Minister
well Jeremy look Jeremy is absolutely
straight as a die and you know the the
the the notion of straight talking
honest politics which was the strap line
in his leadership campaign goes to the
very heart of Jeremy Corwin it
absolutely and indeed you know he is an
anti-racist he has to look to all forms
of races and including anti-semitism and
what I get pretty annoyed about is how
people conflate appalling anti-semitic
abuse online with Labour Party members
and
now hold Jeremy Corbyn responsible the
truth is the Labour Party's done more
than any political party to address
anti-semitism far more than the
Conservative Party and the Conservative
Party is riddled with racism and where
is Anna as Ashe was pointed out where is
Anna in actually standing up to that I'm
afraid she's absent without leave so
there's a couple of points to be taken
up there first of all as a long I was in
the anti-nazi League before Ashe was
even born so I've been fighting racism
all my life secondly second angle I
didn't interrupt you
secondly I don't disagree if there are
bound to be racists in the Conservative
Party but we're talking about the Labour
Party where there has been a rise in
anti-semitism under Jeremy Hogan's
amazement and you say and you say
rubbish yeah Diderot you either mr.
Hansen took Jewish MPs who were so
rightly semitism from Labour Party
members okay
Brit research on this Anna Anna and it's
demonstrated that anti-semitism in the
labour movement is actually lower than
the country at large and furthermore
anti-semitism within the labor movement
and labour supporters has actually
reduced since Jeremy Corbyn became the
leader so for Anna to for Anna
well I'm sorry well look at the research
look at the research daddy blinkered
okay not now are clearly are currently
audience s pretty audience is strongly
agreeing with that Anna moving on from
that one is your party anti-islamic
certainly not and I fell in there are
there no anti-islamic people in the
winery I'm sure there are is there are
in all parties because parties reflect
unfortunately our society look I'm the
co-chair of the appt on for Muslims
British Muslims and one of the things
that we are looking at is the definition
of Islamophobia so that we now move to
putting that into law so Islamophobia of
course is a problem in our society and
frankly I think it's grown since we've
had the referendum I think intolerance
and racism actually has grown
unfortunately in our country system
that's why we all need to come together
and I'll fight it together
I got to ask you a question now about
Europe you have a choice I'm going to
give you a choice of two visions you can
either have Britain still in Europe and
there's a second referendum and we vote
to remain in or going with that is
Jeremy Corbyn and number 10 would you
sooner be in Europe still with Jeremy
Corbyn which would you sooner I've
actually thought about this okay good
while you're carrying on thinking about
the answer the thing is I don't want us
to leave the European Union but if we
leave the European Union at least we can
go back we won't go back on such good
terms but we can go back might take my
daughter's generation to do it but we
can go back if you get Jeremy Corbyn
into number 10
god help our country and you won't be
able to get rid of him for five years
and the damage you will do will be even
greater well let's take that very point
because Chris you mentioned yourself
that he's 68 in fact he's 69 that means
he might not be 73 til he goes in and
that means he might not be 78 who comes
out 83 after another term I mean even
gladsome is only 82 in Churchill 80 I
mean that's getting on a bit isn't it
we're talking about Fitness here
it really gonna be fit I mean some
people say it's very fit now but would
it still be fit in office at that age of
course you will endure the 60 is the new
30 for the start and Jeremy Corbyn is
also bordering on a vegan and the vegans
are going to inherit the earth so he's
incredibly healthy I don't think he
drinks very much and he is driven to
actually create a better country
absolutely so yes of course he'll be fit
enough and he's got the energy
indeed angela regal said i don't know
how he does it during the referendum
campaign he has the energy of a 25 year
old Jeremy Corbyn did more than any
leader of any political party to secure
a remain vote and he was absolutely
right he was absolutely right when he
said when he gave the European Union
seven out of ten because I tell you what
the reason why the British people voted
against the European voted to come out
was because of the policies of the
people like Anna sugery because she's
had abandoned whole swathe of our
industrial heartland it had abandoned
working-class communities and they were
sick to the back teeth of it and they
wanted something different now I think
they were misplaced their view but that
was the problem it was absolutely not
down to Jeremy Corbyn and as I say
straight talking on his politics jeremy
tells it how he sees it god he felt
seven out of ten was the appropriate
score to give your opinion so he gave an
honest answer
and he's been pilloried for telling the
truth yeah thank you very much indeed
but just coming on to questions now so
let's have the lights up and we're going
to just see and then I wanted to get a
moment of quiet consensus between both
sides before we went into retrieve that
here and we're going to have the first
question there is a lady in the front
row I want to see a second question I
want to go over on this side at the back
yes somebody over there is going to take
the second question please right this
debate was about where the Jeremy Corbyn
is fit or unfit to be
Minister it has revolved an awful lot
around anti-semitism two things why is
my synagogue in the center of London
Jewish New Year having to put up the
sort of entrances that normally we see
in airports we've never had that before
and the increase in attacks on Jewish
people has risen with Jeremy Corbyn and
if Jeremy Corbyn is so wonderful why are
you not streaks ahead in the point and
why when he adopts the official
definition of anti of anti-semitism does
he have to put a caveat on it
okay so there's you've spoken too much
panel about anti-semitism but there blow
me down to question on anti-semitism
question number two over there please
stand by question number three yes come
in to Chris you said that Jeremy is a
very good listener but does he hear
anything because I would love to Eve
what evidence you can give of him
changing his mind can you list the
issues where he's changed his mind be at
Venezuela or whatever okay thank you and
question number three over there can he
listen yep I just want to say that I've
been watching Jeremy Corbyn for many
years I've been to many of his meetings
for 10 years we've recorded him and we
know that he's an anti-semite we've
heard him we know that he supports his
Burleigh we know that he supports the
IRA and my question is do the people of
this country really want a prime
minister who has that background and who
lies about it as Howard Jacobson said he
has told lie after lie after lie
his Bellanca or not or not his friends
he says this man tells porky's and he
wants to run our country he wants to run
it as a Marxist country what we need
okay so so thank you very much and I'm
gonna ask you that lady there
what is that lady asked about what is
the worst single thing that you've heard
him say come here the Kretz microphone
back please
Mike back to that lady there I want you
to know very quickly the worst thing in
10 years that you've heard him saying
Jerry Korman refers to Israel as a
racist entity
to me is the worst thing that because
what he's talking about he's not talking
about Israelis actually talking about
Jews Israel is a synonym oh gosh people
thank you thank you very much okay right
Howard do you want me to say the worst
thing I've ever heard him say yeah I
haven't got the time to hear the worst
things he's ever said but I thought when
he said that Zionists have got that's to
say Jews Jews Zionists that change
around as it suits them have got no
sense of irony and don't study history
tell that to Simon Schama and when he
said that they his actual words were
having lived in this country for a very
long time probably all their lives they
don't under having lived in this country
for a very long how to make a section of
this country feel like aliens the cloth
nurse of that year that he does not hear
you could that you can say to people who
have lived in this country for
generations or you've lived here but you
haven't got the part of it I have never
felt and all the Jews I know all said
well that really is the end of whatever
doubts we had before that's the end of
it if you can talk about Jews like that
then there's no hope for him and ask for
this
but I could also add the speech he gave
on Iranian TV because this is a man who
made many appearances on Iranian TV and
Russian TV there's a role for got the
speech he made an Iranian TV to the
Iranians who swear the destruction of
Israel he said I think the BBC is a bit
biased because they seem to think there
is an argument to be made for it for the
survival of Israel there is that Matt
the BBC is biased because he thinks
there is an argument to be made for the
survival of Israel meaning I don't think
there's an argument to be made for the
survival of Israel that's where he
stands on Israel
okay and got that thank you very much
I'm gonna want to identify the people
for the next batch and bring an ash for
the responses to that does he listen
is he in fact an anti see Matt again I
think we've answered that but does it
matter
would he be capable in Downing Street of
ruling in the interests of Jewish people
or would he discriminate against them
I'd like to try and take some of these
questions in one big bunch because I
think the one which went on remarked on
was them by the lady with the fabulous
earrings about this Reisman semitism and
attacks on synagogues but just quickly
in terms of Howard's talking about this
joke is that I think it was a clunky
joke it was a joke which was playing on
more British than the British but I find
it funny that you found that
indefensible whereas you defended the
healing power of Bernhard manning you're
on record saying this you were you know
part of a documentary in which you're in
the front very life and along subscribe
I described the Bernhard Manning that's
what I did I didn't defend him at all
you did the same piece in The Telegraph
described and set that in this channel
for documentary which is the 1927 so
don't watch it I was 5 and was really in
Sesame Street around that time was that
you're in front of I laughing along
while he made awful jokes are Irish
people Jewish people and also use the
n-word so it just seems like a striking
bit of hypocrisy but one of the things I
would like to say till want to come back
to your point about this escalation in
anti-semitism because I think that this
is something which we lose when we zero
in on the Labour Party's internal
is that anti-semitism it particularly
attacks on those who are seen as being
culturally distinctive and in some way
whether those institutions or
individuals to gone hand in hand with
Islamophobia and at the same time you've
had an amplification of anti-semitic
harassment and hate online I think that
this needs to be dealt with by looking
at how our culture reproduces hatred of
those who are deemed to be other who are
deemed to be deviant who are deemed to
not belong here
the problem is the problem with
isolating wait give me a chance response
okay right I listen to you I'm gonna say
thank you very much can you please be
quiet so that everyone else can get on
with the debate
thank you ask your response I'm going to
take three more questions and I would
really like not to have questions on
anti-semitism because it's a bigger
debate tonight than just a BTEC I'm
saying very important but there are
virtually number one go question number
one thank you and entertaining as has
been can we maybe talk more in detail
about the economic policies that jeremy
corbyn listed so is he fit economically
to run the country secondly here
Corbin's mantra for the many not the few
is more suitable to a country like South
Africa in this country the many are the
middle class the few of the downtrodden
so the question is the right politician
but in the wrong country right okay
thank you very much indeed I'm going to
ask Chris to come in first on that and
question number three well as a
partially Jewish person I am absolutely
appalled that this meeting tonight has
been hijacked by the debate about
anti-semitism
I mean frankly we face as has been said
this incredibly serious question about
whether we leave Europe or not it seems
to me that has to be the main burden of
what we should be talking about and
which party let alone whether Jeremy
Corbyn is fit and the fact is we are
being so let down and why is it in fact
we know that the 48-52 result was
absolutely outrageous for us to be taken
forward on the basis of something called
democracy in something so important so
why is this not being discussed in
relation to possibly the labor and to be
fair to Ana she said it was the most
important topic are in the whole of
national politics at the moment Chris
told me that his section on Europe he
didn't have time to come on take Europe
take the economy is Jeremy Corbyn fit to
become Prime Minister later this year or
any time in the next three or four years
well obviously I believe he is clearly
and in terms of economic policies look
we've had four decades of neoliberalism
it's been a total failure it's
completely failed
Hulse waves of our country we've seen
manufacturing jobs offshore to low wage
economies we see people millions of
people in precarious employment we see
our public services being hired off to
the private sector we see our utilities
going the same way they're used as a
cash cow and we see industrial scale tax
evasion and avoidance and we absolutely
have to come down on that and we are
saying that will be an end to
neoliberalism we will have an economy
that does indeed work for the many not
the few we will make sure that the tax
evaders pay their way that the faceless
corporations actually pay their way and
contribute to the public services and
the education and infrastructure that
they rely upon so yes we are a party for
the many not the few and as for the only
boys can see Europe they wear on the
okra okay but Europe listen on your up I
campaigned night and day I was up in the
early hours of the morning on the two
days prior to the vote to leaflet
commuter so I play my part on a spoke at
numerous public meetings we lost the
vote we cannot go back and have another
vote and I tell you what if we were to
go back and I think it's incredibly
irresponsible of anybody from Ana to
chakram owner to constantly be calling
into question the decision that was
taken by the British people as flawed as
it might have been because the decision
has now been taken whether it be 52 48
that's how democracy works and if we
continue down this track and if they
were to be successful in getting another
referendum
I fear we would lose it but worse it
would I think precipitate and even worse
postmodern 1930s crisis arise in the far
right we're seeing the influence of the
far-right in the Conservative Party
already and we would be precipitating a
night mare scenario we need a People's
break say let's focus on that and stop
this piffle about calling for a people's
vote in a second referendum is Wilson's
say no people no people no nonsense if
Jeremy Corbyn had come out really
strongly given how effective he is we've
been hearing has a campaigner if you'd
come out really strongly for a remain
with the votes have been different
Jeremy came out strongly for remain let
me tell you is there on our Nicola
Sturgeon is hailed as a great conquering
heroine who secured exactly the same
percentage of SNP voters voting for
remain a Jeremy Corbyn did it's absurd
it's another proxy war by the people who
are obsessed and we heard a person car
this status quo which has failed
millions of British okay you were given
seven and or if I said to you if you
said what would you mark my speech
tonight and I went seven I'd because
every Howard if he gave you said he
wouldn't I would she'd want ten well I
would but I'll be happy if he if he gave
you seven hour tween ass
I think I think you deserve 10 thank you
for someone to have so few arguments and
to be delivered on with such a key I
think it's fantastic
ok an hour it's piffle so what is
Labour's policy
what's Chris's policy on Breck six
that's the most woman is right that is
the most important question because it
reflects on Corbin's leadership remember
Corbin said we should trigger article 50
the day after the EU referendum do you
think that's a responsible leader to
trigger article 50 of the day after the
EU referendum they have had no policy
until they've been dragged screaming and
kicking to a customs union and the irony
of it is is Chris Williamson talks about
the manufacturing sector unless we have
that frictionless trade in the single
market you will see hundreds of
thousands of jobs will go in the
manufacturing sector so why isn't labour
standing up as now increasingly trade
unions are doing calling for customs
union calling for the single market
calling for an economic outcome have
finally on the people's vote that is
about the deal and I think the people of
this country do have a right now we know
more about what leaf actually means they
do have a right to a say and a vote on a
deal and interestingly the GMB came out
in agreement with that yet another trade
union who Labour's meant to be wedded to
seeing why it's so important that the
deal goes back to the people so they
decide not 650 MPs
okay just out of out of interest hands
up those people who would like a second
referendum people's vote and hands down
hands up who still is in favor of remain
okay good so this is a very brexit order
it's going to take three more questions
now the questioners have to ask
questions in no more than a sentence of
40 words now I'm going to cut you off
then and we're not gonna have we're
gonna pick those points up can the panel
please look what they're saying when
they're asking and at this very moment
here there's final voting on the motion
Jeremy Corbyn is unfit to be Prime
Minister let's take these three
brilliant questions because there are
about 40 or 50 questions these are
brilliant questions question number one
let's go number one in you come all
right this is for Chris Williamson about
five or six times
sorry I'll stand up yeah you use the
phrase neoliberalism yeah I want to know
exactly what you mean when you say that
got that good excellent number two where
is number two we're going to go straight
to number three over there I don't need
to be lectured by Chris Williamson about
anti-semitism but my question is what
government in any country over the last
50 years would you expect Jeremy Corbyn
to most emulate any country the last 50
years thank you very much marvelous and
this is the best question of all coming
in here from tell me can we have a
question on the economy it's for
everybody and particularly Chris command
economies have failed in Russia and
China what you're proposing is to take
central back command and control of our
economy and that has led to the utter
disaster so could you comment really
rich you're much loved tonight everyone
is
to spend gris-gris here are able to sign
autographs ash and picking up in there
any points it sounds strange after this
evening I'm probably filled with more
political optimism than I have in a very
bet that I have been in a really long
time I think that whether you like him
or not hey added or never ignored Jeremy
Corbyn has been part of energizing
political discussion in this country
which we haven't seen for decades as to
what country he will probably emulate
while in government I think there are
strong cases to look at scandinavian
social democracies but ultimately
ultimately the changes that he wants to
bring to the economy are ones that we
haven't seen before because we are
facing economic crises that we haven't
seen before and the responses to those
will have to be radical and it will have
to be creative we'll have to look at how
we distribute the abundance generated by
the automation of Labor we'll have to
look at how you can have a social
housing program which doesn't look like
the big bureaucratic bear mouths of the
60s and the 70s how do you have housing
corpse on a mass scale these are the
kinds of questions that jeremy corbyn's
Labour Party is dedicated to addressing
and alongside that progressive economic
platform you will have a renewed
political culture of anti racism you
cannot have anti racism without that
progressive economic platform you cannot
have a progressive economic platform
without anti racism I'm really filled
with a sense of hope as a young person
who's looked out the economy's locked
out of the housing market that Jeremy
Corbyn and his team will be able to
produce some concrete answers and
solutions to the problems that otherwise
I'd go I think are going to result in a
nosedive in standards of living for the
decades to come we're already looking at
stagnant and falling wages you can look
at club in the personality as much as
you want but take a closer look at the
policies I think let's have another
discussion in a few weeks time thank you
act very much indeed for that
Annagh
I'm old enough to remember when this
country was described as the sick man of
Europe and then joined the European
Union we saw then our country become one
of the most successful fastest-growing
economies in the g7 that's why we have
the jobs the prosperity record levels of
employment now I don't say that we don't
face huge challenges we know that it's
not just about wrecks it we've got to
get it right when it comes to public
expenditure so that we will make sure
that we deliver the great services we
need we've got to make sure we have the
aspiration amongst our young people and
the opportunities they all deserve these
are huge challenges that our country
faces and what we get on offer
from Jeremy Corbyn are the failed
policies there's nothing new about his
economic policies in particular and a
number of you have already identified
where in the world do you see any of
those policies being put in today into
operation and the answer is Venezuela
that's about as near as it gets these
are bankrupt policies they were bankrupt
back in the 70s and it's true today my
final thing I will remind you I asked
you to look at the tests of any great
leader integrity competence the ability
to inspire decision-making
accountability courage and success and I
would argue even if you don't buy the
argument on anti-semitism look at all
the other things that make up the man of
Jeremy Corbyn apply them to those tests
and I would argue he fails on every
single one he must be one of the most
unfit people to be Prime Minister that
we've encountered in British politics
and he's certainly not leading the
Labour Party and I return to that
message millions of decent moderate
tolerant people in our country are only
represented and it's a scandal and it
must change and he must go as part of
that
okay I don't have you've been to
Venezuela but from now on you're both
going to be saying what country he most
would represent if he became leader and
you have to have gone to that country so
Chris you're well let me try and deal
with some of the questions that were
raised and I was asked about my
definition of neoliberalism basically
it's a deregulated market capitalism
with a small state which clearly hasn't
worked as for which countries we would
kind of be similar to I think I may take
your pick across Western Europe really
in terms of the way in which they've
conducted their economic affairs and the
point that was made about a command
economy what we're talking about is
democratizing our economy giving people
a stake in our economy making the
economy work for ordinary people giving
young people a stake giving young people
hope giving young people a career plan
making sure we can care for our elderly
and disabled people and rather than
seeing them as some sort of burden or a
way in which we could make money through
the privatized social care system and as
for Anna's points about Britain being
the sick man of Europe in the 1970s yes
the 1970s definitely had its problems
but economic growth never ever bettered
anything that was achieved during that
period and furthermore every single year
from 1945 through to the introduction of
neoliberalism saw a bigger and bigger
proportion of the national income going
to workers in their wage packets so if
we could replicate that once again we
could get back to the point where
younger Prince's bricklayers like I was
in 1979 could aspire to buy their own
home again as touched upon the challenge
of automation we're embarking upon the
fourth Industrial Revolution are we
seriously going to sit back and leave it
to the neoliberals or are we going to
make sure that we use the benefits that
will flow from the fourth Industrial
Revolution I remember being told to get
ready for the laser generation in the
1960s and 70s because automation was
supposed to be mean little anymore at 10
to 15 hours a week
is now a genuine real possibility but we
need a Corbin led Labour government to
make it happen had not come back
for a moment we had very to explain who
Derrick Hatton is I'm a young person I
wasn't around in the 70s myself the
wonderful thing about hearing Kris
Williamson is I now understand what
happy did you know he runs a road show
he goes up and down the country doing
this road show where you deselect people
I thought road shows were places where
you chose a record on the beach but
apparently not you go onto the beach you
choose somebody you'd like to select and
Chris Williams says ok I'll deselect
them for you on the grounds that
deselection is such an important part of
the Labour Party at the moment and I
think the place Jeremy should go to to
learn a lesson is Israel and he should
talk to some Israelis and maybe if
they're if the country is as apartheid
is ISA successfully apartheid as he says
it is which is total bladder because
it's not true in the slightest bit in
the slightest fit through but since he
thinks it is maybe he can learn a few
lessons then because apartheid is what
you're practicing in your country in
your party you don't want any other
voices anybody who speaks other than you
you deselect you call that a labour
party when you think of the great
tradition of the Labour Party the
wonderful radical moralistic Christian
political socialistic tradition from
which the Labour Party has grown those
wonderful men of the 18th and 19th
century and it's come to this you don't
agree with us you deselect it you should
be ashamed of what you've done to your
own once great party
Howard you still got another 10 seconds
can you do that gesture again example
should be ashamed of what you've done
your once great part I've got 14 seconds
you well I give those to Chris Chris
well listen our party is growing
exponentially and I'm absolutely proud
of my party proud of Jeremy Corbyn and
we're going to transform this country
I'm sorry everyone it has been such such
a dull quiet debate here I've got now
ringing in both my ears severe tinnitus
from these people and been kicked under
the table too and but I do have the
result for you and resort I think shows
that we know why the f we are here
tonight V for the motion that who these
people think that is unfit and there are
some 800 people here tonight it was 66
and it has gone down if that's a false
fact it's gone down to 85% 85% and
against has also gone up up from a 13%
to 14% therefore we could say that
everyone's a winner
everyone's winner are but Howard what
really I think is shameful is that there
was apparently one person here tonight
on the data I've got who didn't know but
I've also been tell here that they
thought they come to a wrong debate they
thought they've come to a vegetarian
Society meeting tonight so if you want
to identify yourself I panic a here is
in the front row and we'll refund your
money so that you might come back again
thank you for being a great audience
thank you bring a spectacular panel
you